à
quantum on sait quelque chose en cela la
vérité on aura peut-être une autre
approche de la situation
on avait un autre haut rang seront
valeur à permettre d'apaiser la douleur
il jouait préféré connaître la vérité
parce qu'avec la vérité on peut vivre
différemment on peut bien rire quand je
suis là c'est comme gta le 16 août 2005
j'ai réalisé
non j'ai entendu je ne le suis pas
et jusqu'à présent je ne me suis pas
appliquée je l'aï c'est comme si je suis
spectatrice toujours de ce qui s'est
passé je veux revoir à une heure du
matin
on s'était un peu froid
d'attendre avec mon fils centraide
attentes
les deux dames venues y avait un moyen
pompiers je ne pleurais pas je ne disais
rien personne mais il savait que j'étais
en attente
là là je me suis dit bon il ya eu
quelque chose me croit le 16 août 2005
le vol wcw 708 a décollé de l'aéroport
international de tokyo mais nous palamas
à 5h59 utc à destination de l'aéroport
international de martinique selon le
dossier d'instruction
l'avion a rencontré une formation
nuageuse de type cumulonimbus avec de
fortes précipitations
une fois atteint les 33 mille pieds
l'appareil a commencé une perte continue
de sa vitesse jusqu'à atteindre la
valeur minimale de sustentation plus
tard il est entré en condition de
décrochage suivi d'une chute constante
d'altitude jusqu'à l'impact au sol près
d'une agglomération de matic s dans
l'état de zulia au venezuela
chez mon nom c'est là que j'ai appris la
nouvelle j'ai téléphoné et il m'a dit
simplement ton frère était dans l'avion
et lorsqu'il m'a dit ça j'ai poussé un
hurlement et j'ai laissé tomber le
téléphone et je crois que c'est quelque
chose que je sais pas c'est c'était
comme si le monde s'écroulait autour de
moi ma souffrance
c'est d'imaginer leur dernière heure
comment résister qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait je me pose tout temps la question
est-ce qu'ils ont souffert
qu'est ce qu'ils ont ressenti je suis à
ce moment là à leur place
je ne lui en même temps qu'eux
et
la difficulté pour connaître la vérité à
mon avis vient du fait qu'il y à une
imbrication de beaucoup de pays dans ce
qu il ya beaucoup de pays c'est un avion
colombien qui parle du panama avec des
martiniquais c'est un avion qui a été
construit aux états unis mcdonald's
douglas et c'est un navire qui tangue au
venezuela
vous n'avez pas moins de cinq pays qui
sont directement poussé en hébreu avant
d'analyser point par point les
différents éléments en cause dans cette
catastrophe
un retour sur les faits s'impose deux
jours après la catastrophe
dès le 18 août une information est
ouverte au tribunal de grande instance
de fort de france pour homicides
involontaires
environ 900 personnes se constitue
partie civile
le 7 septembre 2005 l'association des
victimes de la catastrophe aérienne du
16 août la fca est déclarée elle reçoit
l'agrément du ministère de la justice
cinq mois plus tard le 5 avril 2007 le
juge organise une première réunion
d'étape avec les familles tout au long
de la procédure de nombreuses demandes
d'actes sont déposés par l'afcai ses
avocats elles sont systématiquement
rejetées
le 11 décembre 2009 l'afg a saisi la
chambre de l'instruction
dans son arrêt en janvier 2011 l homme
donne la traduction du dossier de
maintenance et la re lecture des boîtes
noires
pourtant que dans un rapport
complémentaire les experts officiels
mais tiennent leur analyse
la chambre de l'instruction va être
amené à prendre une position nous donne
raison sur l'essentiel en suisse à
savoir ce que cet arrêt jusqu'à ce jour
n'a pas été respecté le 21 mai 2015 avec
is it was de non lieu est rendu peu
après une requête en dépaysement est
déposée par la fca enfin le 26 juin 2015
l'ordonnancé de non-lieu est rendu et
trois jours plus tard le 29
la demande de dépaysement est rejetée
dix ans de procédure dix ans de combat
et d'espoir et la mémoire d'une
souffrance indélébile
le temps ne doit pas effacer l'image
allait au pot le temps ne pourra pas
effacer les 152 celle que j sur le
tarmac de l'aéroport le temps le poids
pas effacer l enterrement de masseube le
temps ne pourra pas effacer et de voir
le le chagrin des familles la souffrance
des familles les valadine on est en fait
comme ils sont pas un terreau et en
valeur deux jours de plus tous quand je
les ai pas vus montre et je me suis dit
à un choix qu'ils ont mis au jour des
vacances en plus monsieur l'avs ai je
pris mon petit déjeuner le téléphone
n'arrête pas de sonner donc je vous
admire
puis-je à ripon on me demande comment va
moi je dis non non elle revient d'un mec
je raccroche parce que c'est un fait
cinq six fois et puis jusqu'à ce que
quelqu'un est cette personne ne sait pas
que je lui en ai voulu pendant des
années elle ne le sait pas je lui
pardonnais mais elle n'imagine pas le
ballack amap est belle mais alors elle
est notamment jeudi mais pas la moins
bien de même a dit mais comment tu as
vendredi pas dans la région jeudi mais
quel avion dès 8 heures du matin le
domaine 15 août voilà je vais bosser
elle me fit mais l'avion qui s'est
écrasé
avant d'arriver à 2,015 j'ai entendu de
nombreux avions de l'otan
il
le secteur s'est faite un fils de et
demi je suis rentré chez moi
le restaurer et me doucher parce que je
n'étais au courant de rien et une
collègue m'appelle et me dit j'aime y
arriver je suis d nous l'avions du
routard et elle me dit il ya un avion
venant de panama qui qui est tombée et a
pas de survivant je suis dit mais qu'est
ce que tu m'as et puis elle m'a dit bon
je ne sais pas si c'est la même subi
mais je te dis et puis après j'ai eu des
amis des bois celles qui m'ont appelé
tout et puis ça a été vraiment jeunes
gens par les gens qui ont mal ça a été
quelque chose d'un prof
la nouvelle que l'on attendait depuis le
début de cette matinée donc l' annonce
officielle tout à l'heure donc vers midi
que cette catastrophe donc effectivement
fait au moins 150 morts d'où ce
martiniquais
j'ai perdu ma fille
noah et je dis aussi que j'ai perdu
jimmy aussi du milieu jeannot qu'elle
son petit financer est vraiment le 16
août 2005 quand on m'a annoncé sa saison
le choc le cauchemar la cauchemar dans
lequel je me trouve toujours d'ailleurs
et pendant ils souffrent ski qui en
permanence qui est un peu plus forte
chaque jour ça comme espace g la réelle
conviction qu'il existe de nombreuses
nombreuses zones sombres puisque je ne
sais pas qui est ce qu'on couvre qui
nous votons protéger en tout cas je suis
convaincue que c'est pas tout n'est pas
dit là beaucoup de choses qui se sont
cachés
cette impression de choses cachées ou
tout au moins de zones d'ombré et
corroborés par l'observation de
certaines contradictions notamment dans
le rapport technique finale est signalé
l'absence de témoins oculaires
oh certains témoignages ont été diffusés
par les télévisions vénézuéliennes
alors qui croire
l'as wihr arrivait avec le côté droit en
flammes le bruit qu'il faisait m'a
réveillé et un instant après l'explosion
après l'explosion l'incendié a commencé
il était 3 heures du matin un quart
d'heure après l'explosion et le début de
l' incendie il a commencé à pleuvoir
c'est ce qui a éteint les flammes
quand l'avion est passé en flammes il
penchait du côté droit
un instant plus tard on a entendu
l'explosion et on a vu les flammes de
l'incendié qui a commencé après
l'explosion on dit que l'avion était en
flammes vous avez pu voir que l'avion se
déplace en flammes oui du côté droit
oui il était en flammes il se déplaçait
avec le côté droit en flammes un instant
après son passage
il ya une explosion les flammes sont
montées et un quart d'heure plus tard il
a commencé à pleuvoir
c'est tout ce que j'ai vu à 3 heures du
matin
autre contradiction selon les éléments
du juge des autorités vénézuéliennes ont
restitué dès le lendemain de la
catastrophe les codes de l'équipage sans
pratiquer d'autopsié ou de prélèvement
sur l'équipage de conduite c'est à dire
le pilote et son copilote
les autorités colombiennes en restituer
les corps aux familles qui les ont
incinéré sans faire plus
d'investigations il n'y a eu aucun
examen toxicologique d'imprégnation
alcoolique ou de recherche
d'intoxication au monoxyde de carbone
pratiqués sur les personnels navigants
techniques
or dans le rapport final du venezuela il
a précisé que les autopsies pratiquées
n'ont pas prouvé la présence de
substances susceptibles d'affecter le
comportement de l'équipage de plus le
témoignage de carlos peña le père de
l'hôtesse de l'air angie la peña
confirme que les com n'ont pas été
incinéré afin d'être mises à la
disposition de l'en quête
tata aussi data c'était le diminutif
d'en généraliser la maison kata donc
disais toujours la même chose si elle
arrivait oui elle ne vous laissera être
enterrée mais incinérés mais ce n'est
pas possible nous n'avons pas pu
respecter cette volonté parce que elle
est morte dans un accident aérien et à
n'importe quel moment ils peuvent tirer
les conclusions qui portent atteinte à
l'équipage des investigations postérieur
pourraient être nécessaires
et si le cadavre est incinéré on ne
pourrait causer certains éléments qui
pouvaient altérer la vérité sur
l'accident
j venezuela après la catastrophe
j'ai vu des choses je suis pas allé sur
les lieux mais j'ai autre chose que j'ai
vue c'est mon cerveau là et ça me
revient tout le temps tout le temps je
sais images dans ma tête
l'amant qu'on avait elle précisé
de là
sûr satisfait ce ressentiment que
j'avais ce ressenti que j'appelle ce que
je me suis approché le
de l'amour qu'ils avaient fait est que
je savais qu'elle était là que je
pourrais pas la prochaine nous simples
qu'elles étaient là on s'en tire en
présence et quand elle le bus a laissé
la manque jamais il ya son
l'impression que je les sais la fille
pour faire déjouer la donne dans ma tête
un départ menti ni car elle est toujours
un visionnaire c'est là qu'il fallait
que pendant des amis là ça revient
malheureusement
2 heures du matin j'entendais le bruit
de l'avion
j'étais réveillé j'entendais le bruit de
la jean seberg
ce écologique un mail mais alors des
fois de ne pas longtemps nous d'attendre
ou passe
le paquet je comprenais bon forcément le
transport aérien
le transfert à l'hôtel les exclusions
les exclusions pardon sur l'autel de
cameron la formule all inclusive et puis
donc l'hébergement en chambre double et
puis la demi pension
voilà et puis bon les taxes d'aéroport
et qui était aussi
comprises dans le tarif de 1200 euros
avec frais c est l espèce d'engouement
ou de folie des gens pour pouvoir aller
comme on avait envie d'aller au panama
c'était un prix quand même extrêmement
intéressant ça il faut le reconnaître et
dites vous bien que pouvoir faire des
économies on va déjà les premiers
économie on le fait sur la qualité de
l'avion et de toutes les façons le
broker le broker aussi le contenu pour
faire doubler par quoi il faisait son
produit et puis c'est tout déjà en 2002
plus d'une centaine de jeunes
martiniquais s'étaient retrouvés piégés
au canada lors des 17e journées
mondiales de la jeunesse à toronto
jacques si métier était l'organisateur
de ce voyage avec les agences kateia et
gary d'as il avait vendu des package
comprenant la société ea canada charter
laquelle avait fait faillite pendant les
jmj les jeunes n'avait alors aucun moyen
de transport pour le retour que ce
métier est un point essentiel en bus
il est basé à miss et de l'udc en
relation avec les deux agents 24 qu'à
l'origine du projet et c'est lui qui va
être l'intermédiaire entre les annonces
de la west
mais en face on compte qu'il est plus
que ça parce qu'un vote contre celui qui
va être lu mes gains terminé en entre la
2g assez selon la loi les opérations
ayant trait à l'organisation à la vente
de voyages ou séjours individuels ou
collectifs ne doivent être effectuées
que par des personnes physiques ou
morales titulaire d'une licence d'agent
de voyages jaaksi moutier ne répondez
pas à ces critères
pourtant il est transporteur de fait il
a organisé le voyage et toutes les
prestations annexes transport avion
intéresse hôtel excursions et cetera
il perçoit directement de lagence
globe-trotter le prix de ses prestations
c'est encore lui qui a choisi la
compagnie west caribbean airways
plus étrange encore une investigation
sur l'approvisionnement en pièces
détachées a été demandé aux juges
car le mot poke her figurent notamment
sur la liste des fournisseurs de la
compagnie lors de son audition devant la
cour fédérale de miami le 7 mai 2007
jacques cimentier reconnaît avoir acheté
et acheminé des pièces pour le compte de
la west caribbean mais il n'a pas été en
mesure d'indiquer l'identité réelle des
fournisseurs auprès desquels il
s'approvisionnait le juge américain
considère que l'origine des pièces
suspectes
c'est uniquement par le biais de la
procédure civile américaine
que ces informations sont révélés mais
aucune investigation sérieuse n'a été
faite sur ces points dans la procédure
pénale française en matière de sécurité
aérienne
l'agent de voyage est tenue par des
obligations la prudence dans le choix
des prestataires et leur surveillance
est la première d'entre elles l'agent
snop trotter avait donc l'obligation de
vérifier le produit vendu
de plus ces vallées 10v âcre qui
possédait la licence mais curieusement
c'est son mari qui signait les documents
ils n'ont jamais été inquiétés par la
justice
je pense que mes confrères qui ont si on
fait confiance aux brokers ont été très
léger pour la bonne raison que autant
que je peux vous dire que je pourrai
affrété une compagnie convient de cas
que la compagnie nationale
internationale de colombie par contre il
est connu par tous ceux qui ont une
expérience dans l'aviation et dans le
tourisme que les vieux avions du monde
entier circulent à l'été de l'amérique
du sud et de l'afrique
donc je peux vous dire que la west
caribbean aucune chance
les pilotes sont accusés d'être
responsables du décrochage en ayant
choisi la mauvaise route en ayant
surchargé l'avion en étant monté trop
haut doubs la sortie du domaine de vol
ce qui a créé le décrochage ils sont
également accusés de n'avoir pas su
gérer ce décrochage et même de l'avoir
aggravé en faisant le contraire de ce
qui aurait dû être fait c'est à dire
encadrant la viande au lieu de le faire
piquer pour retrouver de la vitesse et
de la portance cependant d'après les
éléments développés dans ce film tout
ces prétendues fautes peuvent être
nuancée et surtout ne pas incomber au
seul pilote cette affaire une histoire
le pjak moi ça ne me dérangeait comme
d'habitude ils peuvent avoir plus ou
moins bien fonctionné en effet mais
c'est volontairement occultée en mettant
leurs projecteurs sur l'équipage c'est
occulter tous les dysfonctionnements
qu'il y a eu en amont qui ont permis cet
accident
ça c'est le tableau de contrôle de
l'avion
c'est l'avion qui est tombé qui je suis
allé chercher mon fils à maracaibo et je
les ramener ici nous sommes restés là
quatre jours à la recherche de mon fils
nous avons eu des difficultés pour le
retrouver
c'est une catastrophe très dur
des tas de gens écartelé en morceaux
j'ai retrouvé mon fils en bon état
entier il était sérieusement blessé mais
je l'ait reconnu grâce à dieu je les
retrouvais entier ici les 50 il a été
diplômé copilote à l'école des algues
honni
ce jour là il a reçu son diplôme
en 2010 le 14 novembre 2002 à l'académie
en turc n y d aviation
il s'est présenté à la west caribbean et
a commencé à piloter
il a fait un cours de formation pour le
let
sept mois plus tard la west caribbean
acquis en avion un des 80
il a donc fait le cours de formation
pour ce type d'avion aux états unis a
commencé à le piloter
ça fait déjà un an et trois mois qu'il
vole avec les rebelles
ce 16 août 2005 une des difficultés
rencontrées par les pilotes et la météo
très difficiles sur le trajet vous comme
le précise une conclusion du dossier
l'équipage confronté à ces masses
nuageuses et orageuse a effectué
plusieurs contournement durant le vol
l'équipage mentionne à plusieurs
reprises subir de nouvelles conditions
météo mais les pilotes disposent est il
d'une information fiable du radar de
l'avion un élément de réponse nous est
donnée par carlos andres gomez et verra
pilotes et techniciens de l'ouest je me
souviens dit il que le radar fonctionne
et puis ne fonctionnait pas
quand je dis qu'il fonctionnait puis de
fonctionner pas c'est que son
fonctionnement été intermittent mais il
fonctionnait bien sûr la majorité des
vols
awesome on réalise un contrôle préalable
au vol avec l'avion it où les
diagnostics étaient satisfaisants mais
quand nous partions en vol il présentait
des indications erratique qui n'était
pas très constante
suit par l'avion on regarde la météo les
pilotes ils ont ils ont pas choisi de
route ils ont pris la route déposée par
la compagnie point bas c'est ce qu'ont
fait tous d'ailleurs 99 fois sur 100
parce que ces routes là elles sont
étudiées en fonction des flux trafic via
un tas de bonnes raisons que ces routes
existent évidemment ces routes peuvent
nous amener dans des situations météo
défavorable ce soir là de toute façon
quand même
il y avait une zone bien identifiés
perturbé clairement identifiés et moi ce
que j'ai pu observer tout simplement en
regardant la carte satellite de ce
journal c'est que la route qui passait
au nord de cette zone était dégagé cette
route-là paraissait plus approprié alors
encore une fois pour changer de route et
il ya un certain nombre de formalités
affaires de retard à accepter est la
pression de la compagnie pour tenir
l'horaire est donc réengager l'aviron
sur noël des six nations derrière doit
être forte pour va suivre sur le plan de
vol prévues sont sans délai omar ospina
le commandant de bord du vol 708 avait
une certaine expérience
voici le témoignage de carlos andres
gomez herrera qui avait eu l'occasion de
piloter en sa compagnie je me souviens
du professionnalisme du pilote et du bon
accomplissement de ses fonctions le
capitaine avait beaucoup d'expérience
sur l'équipement dc-9 qu'il a pilotée
sur la compagnie aérienne
intercontinental des aviacion et qui est
très semblable à la série md81 et md90
maintenant les pressions les pressions
subies par les équipages sont on dit
quand j'entends le procureur dire ah oui
mais s'ils avaient les cartes
enfin il aurait dû choisir la route qui
est plus au nord évidemment oui sauf que
ce qu'ils avaient les cartes
est ce que la compagnie d'assistance
faisait son travail est ce que voilà
la société d'assistance au sol est
chargé du calcul de la masse de l'avion
en tenant compte du poids à vide du
carburant des passagers et des bagages
en outre elle doit communiquer au
commandant de bord la météo le long du
trajet ces éléments permettent d'établir
le plan de vol entrant dans la
composition du dossier de vol dans le
cas du vol 708 chacun de ces éléments
posent question pour le poids des
passagers c'est un calcul statistique
dans d'autres cas le devis de masse
indique un poids forfaitaire de 75 kg 38
par passager ce poids comprend celui du
passager et celui du bagage en cabine
à titre de comparaison sur un vol
charter la compagnie air caraïbes estime
ce point à 84 kg par passager
conclusions de l'enquêté dans tous les
cas nous constatons que l'estimation de
la compagnie aérienne du poids des
passagers est bien en dessous des poids
calculé avec les données constructeur ou
du minimum qui se pratique en france
nous pouvons donc en conclure que le
poids des passagers estimés à 75 kg est
trop inférieur au poids réel
voilà donc ici les martiniquais arrivé
ici tous les bagages étaient disposés
sur le trottoir chacun récupérer son
bagage et ensuite on se dirigeait vers
le hall d'entrée pour l'enregistrement
voilà ici donc nous appelions le
personnel et puis les gens se ranger sur
deux fils pour pouvoir procéder à
l'enregistrement pour leurs avions de
retour la martinique les bagages des
qu'absolument en pas pesé moi je suis
arrivé je vous dis par accident donc
fait quelques achats mais pas beaucoup
donc j'étais dans les normes je dirais
bagages mais j'ai vu des gens passés
avec des valises énorme sans que ce soit
pesé on est arrivés à l'aéroport ils
doivent être qu'est le 20h et l'avion
est parti dans la nuit à nouveau et on a
vu quelqu'un arriver au comptoir et
faire passer des bagages à tour de bras
sans qu'il n'y ait ni pour les bagages
passé sur la balance il s'était pas
posée il était simplement posée est est
étiqueté c'est tout donc il n'y avait
aucun contrôle du poids des bagages dans
l'avion aucun
en tout cas devant nous on arrivait elle
a bon dos manquements et tout le monde
d'épousés les bagages dans les autres
comme ça y'est pas à coup sûr les
barrages ne vais pas passer ça c'est sûr
les bagages n'est pas posée
puisque on arrivait à la borne et on
nous remettait des tickets on n'est pas
honnête a une vraie carte d'embarquement
ça c'est un truc et on n'avait pas de
compte bancaire et on déposait les
bagages chaque personne déposer ses
bagages et bagages été pris comme ça et
j'ai pas on n'y a pas de poids on ne
remet tait pas un ticket avec le point
de tomber à gages est pas ça ça c'est un
ticket sur les investigations menées à
panama auprès de la société balboa
logistique ce montre qu'elle aurait
chargé 71 bagages dans la soute numéro 3
et 132 dans la soute numéro 4 les soutes
1 et 2 selon la feuille de répartition
serait vide
cependant les auditions des
manutentionnaires en martinique
divergent quelque peu les semaines
précédentes ils avaient déjà déchargé
les bagages des vols de la west et à
chaque fois tout les soutes avant et
arrière de 1 à 4 était pleine par
ailleurs les enquêteurs ont mené des
investigations sur le rapatriement des
ressortissants rester au panama suite à
la perte du seul appareil encore en vol
de la wta
ces voyages ont été exécutés par la
compagnie air france et ils ont permis
d'établir le poids des bagages de soute
habituellement embarqué sur ce type de
liaison
cette étude montre qu'au retour du
panama les poissons bien supérieur au
poids déclaré de 18 kg par passager par
le service des opérations au sol de la
wca sur air france ils ont été de 23 à
28 kg par passager
ce que deux
pilote expérimenté c'est pas quelqu'un
qui débute dans le métier il devait
savoir que son avion au poids
au poids qui des réelles qu'ils avaient
mais ça lui le connaissais pas ce point
mais s'il avait connu le poids réel de
l'avion normalement il devait passer de
monter aux 330 ou alors de façon
vraiment très temporaire en
convertissant
la vitesse acquise à un niveau inférieur
pour la convertir en pente mais vraiment
de façon temporaire et en surveillant de
très près
les instruments et en particulier
l'indicateur de vitesse or cet avion là
ils volaient manifestement au dessus de
son plafond de propulsion puisque la
vitesse mais des crottes les
investigations effectuées à partir de la
boîte noire et du manuel de vol
constructeurs montrent que la masse de
l'aéronef au décollage pouvait avoisiner
155 mille livres alors que la masse
maximale au décollage autorisé est de
149 1500 livres
certes le devis de masse fournis par la
société balboa indique un poids de 140
8000 livres au décollage mais cela ne
correspond pas au poids réel embarqué
c'est de toute évidence un document est
sonné selon les experts cette surcharge
est un facteur contributif dans la
survenance de l'accident or la société
balboa n'a jamais été inquiété
il faut voir la société qui est
responsable de cette société japonaise
basée au panama
on connaît le nom connaît ce responsable
disons pour fumer un nom puisqu'elle n'a
pas respecté réglementation on n'a
manifestement pas envie de se creuser
poney club à damas et quand vous avez le
problème du plan de vol qu'on a donné à
au pilote où manifestement et semble
qu'on l'aurait caché l'information que
la voie habituelle est une voie
extrêmement nuageuse susceptibles
d'aller un climatique pour cette nuit
fatidique en lançant ble ment pas donné
cette information en était donc ça pose
deux problèmes de caisse kong
alors si l'équipage évidemment ne
dispose pas de l'information en route
qui est une information obligatoire
réglementaire bon d'abord déjà normal
mais doit partir et mais évidemment il
faut pas choisir soit on prend la route
qui est déposée par la compagnie
l'aviation civile panaméenne a demandé
dans les heures qui ont suivi l'accident
à gary acosta le gérant de balboa
logistics de lui remettre copie des
informations correspondant au vol dans
ce dossier remis à l'équipage tous les
éléments météo doivent figurer
pourtant les documents remis aux
magistrats français ne comporte qu'une
liste obtenue sur internet est
postérieur à l'accident contrairement à
la déclaration du gérant il n'y avait
aucune indication sur les phénomènes
météo en route ni sur les cartes des
vents aucune information non plus
concernant les aéroports de départ de
déroutement et de destination et encore
moins sur les conditions météorologiques
sur le trajet le commandant de bord
aurait signé le dossier de vol mais
l'original de ce dernier présent dans la
viande a été détruit lors de l'accident
et les compagnies ouest et balboa
logistique ne détiennent pas de double
ils en ont pourtant l'obligation selon
la convention de l'organisation de
l'aviation civile internationale oaci
conventions ratifiées par la colombie et
comme le précise l'enquète les éléments
recueillis conduisent à conclure que les
différentes décisions qu'ils nomment de
la préparation du vol par le responsable
des opérations au sol et pape le
commandant de bord sont hors normes et
constituent les premiers éléments
pouvant être qualifiés de contributifs à
la survenance de l'accident
donc ce dossier il y avait suffisamment
d'éléments pour qu'on comprenne que les
pilotes avaient été induit en erreur et
que ça vraiment super pour notre en
cause également d'autres personnes
on a un rapport qu'il me dit très
clairement que le signal qui avertit
qu'il y a décrochage bas ce signal il
arrive trop tardivement
de sorte que les pilotes n'ont pas un
temps de réaction suffisant cela veut
dire quoi ça veut dire tout simplement
combien même le décrochage a eu lieu ces
pilotes n'avaient pas un temps de
réaction suffisant alors comment
comprendre que là aussi on n'est pas les
moyens de pousser les investigations à
savoir si il n'y a pas un problème de
conception de l'aéronef
initialement c'est la commission
internationale qu'on appellera julian
qui a commencé à poser la problématique
des conditions dans lesquelles les
pilotes avaient des informations son
éventuel décrochage ce qui était
frappant est que la procédure a révélé
dès le début c'est qu'on ne comprenait
pas ce qui était j'allais dire le
l'absence de panique de la part des
pilotes par rapport à ceux qui tentent
de se passer un des éléments
d'explication et la commission
internationale mais c'est que
manifestement les pilotes n'ont pas reçu
toutes les informations de la part de
l'appareil de ce qui était en train de
se passer et nous avons fait faire aux
frais de l'être qu'à une expertise qui
revient sur sa pause 3 compromettre sa
pose la problématique de la
responsabilité de boeing parfois de côté
et juge que nous avons là ne sont pas
capables ou non pas le courage ne
veulent pas je ne sais pas en tout cas
de fait ils ne le font pas de mettre en
cause
certaines conclusions de ce rapport
commandé par la fca sont précieuses le
commandant de bord n'a pas été aidé par
les alam
le tremblement de l'avion autrement dit
peuvent-ils survient en l'absence de
tout autre alarme si les avertisseurs
classique avait été associé à une
situation de basse vitesse le pilote
aurait immédiatement compris que la
procédure à mettre en oeuvre est une
sortie de décrochage mais les vibrations
sans alerte complémentaires peuvent être
le signe d'une survitesse et dans ce cas
la procédure à appliquer est totalement
différente
il est donc tout à fait possible
d'affirmer que lorsque les alarmes
mécaniques se sont activés le temps
laissé aux pilotes aux comprendre cette
situation a été telle que le décrochage
était pratiquement inévitable il est
donc clair que les systèmes installés le
répondait pas complètement à leurs
fonctions dans toutes les phases de vol
ni totalement aux règlements applicables
établi dans la procédure que quelques
heures après le crash
il ya des gens qui sont allés sur place
qui ont signé une partie qu'ils ont
peut-être surgelés pièce tu étais un
élément important parce que c'était déjà
un élément tse signalé nombreux crashs
il est parfaitement possible parce qu'on
a vu que la pièce était au moment de
leur camp après on a étudié mais que
s'est il passé amati caisse sur l'épave
de l'avion et qui a opéré selon le
dossier d'instruction
une ouverture importante avoisinant le
mètre carré a été pratiquée à la
disqueuse dans la tôle de revêtement du
flanc gauche de la dérive l'ouverture a
été effectuée à tâtons et par couches
successives
une telle ouverture ne semblait pas être
connues des enquêteurs vénézuélien une
telle ouverture avec une disqueuse
nécessite la mise à disposition
d'alimentation électrique et donc d'une
logistique conséquente et planifiée elle
suppose également de la part de son
auteur une connaissance approfondie du
système ainsi que certaines informations
tirées de la boîte noire
l'origine du crash c'est un état qui n'a
pas rempli ses obligations d'état de
protéger ses seconds
quand on lui en août lancée il ya deux
aspects de responsable sur le premier
aspect c'est qu'ils disent qu'en fin de
compte ne rien vérifié sinon d'aller
vérifier la fameuse liste noire de
l'union européenne où ils disent il y en
a aucune des rôles avec du sud qui est
noir où il ya pratiquement personne
c'est la seule chose qu'ils ont fait ils
n'ont rien fait d'autre
et puis la deuxième chose c'est qu'ils
nous ont menti elle nous a raconté
nous étions en contact avec la presse
elle a jamais est en route avec la west
est en contact avec nos vies cynthia si
une des deux demandes concernant
l'ensemble des vols a été signé par le
directeur des opérations de la west le
représentant de la dg assez des claques
l'ensemble de ses vols concernant les
deux demandes a été transmis par jacques
six métiers agissant pour le compte d'
agences antillaise et surtout un extrait
du dossier note qu'aucune personne ni
organisation intéressée par le vol
charter 708 du 16 août 2005 n'a demandé
à l'aviation civile de colombie une
attestation ou une certification en
relation avec la compagnie wca quant à
déverser de paris sans aucune
consultation de la déjà assez d'eau
colombie prend la décision d'autoriser
cette compagnie dont on va savoir après
qu'elle avait déjà eu beaucoup
d'incidents qu'il avait déjà eu beaucoup
d'infractions
en réalité à faire on vole la dg assez
de paris manifestement ne protège pas le
ressortissant le citoyen qui lui quand
il va prendre un avion il pense que les
autorités en plus obligés sûr et ça faut
pas oublier même si ce n'est pas l'objet
de la procédure pénale
ce n'est pas c'est l'origine de tout
alors pourquoi ce n'est pas une
infraction pénale
il se fait que
nous sommes d'un domaine roues une fois
faire ce qu'on appelle une
interprétation stricte des textes en
l'homicide involontaire implique que
pour que celui ci soit constitué qu'il
faut surtout si ces fonctionnaires qui
les violer sciemment un règlement or à
notre grande surprise nous avons
découvert qu'en 2005 il n'y avait aucune
réglementation qui existe est faisant
que les fonctionnaires en france une
demande venant de l'étranger pour
français était tenu à respecter une
réglementation
il y en a le bas c'est après le crash
qu'on a créé cette réglementation en
europe on a vu apparaître sur le site de
la dg à ces documents qui étaient en
triant pas en les compagnies extérieures
sur ce point est donc et dans les
guerres pas de réglementation donc a pas
eu violation des réglementations
on a estimé que cette infraction pénale
dans le cadre du fonctionnaire n'existe
pas si vous êtes devront engager la
procédure de vente administratifs
parmi les éléments pour le moins
étonnant l'immatriculation de l'avion
étaient provisoires au moment de
l'accident et pour cause la compagnie
wca n'a jamais fourni la copie du titre
de propriété de l'avion ni le certificat
de non implication dans le narcotrafic
le certificat de navigabilité lui était
valable jusqu'au 21 août alors que les
vols étaient prévus jusqu'à fin août
pour 158 personnes passagers + équipage
la catastrophe a fait 168 team
c'était la secrétaire d'état aux
transports monsieur baroin qui disait
que avec les premiers éléments qu'ils
avaient quelqu'un argenté l'avion avec
un passé qui avait été le début de
désert aux canards et oies messieurs
août que les autorités françaises se
serait beaucoup plus hauts gardons sur
cet avion qui risquait de ne pas tirer
trop peu
et
réalité au panama cinq ans qui y
habitaient tous de 15 ans et j'ai été
embauché par prix de production
française pour faire un documentaire sur
cet accident
c'est comme ça te en 2005 avec mon
équipe je suis arrivé à mai dernier mais
je suis allé donc fini mais aussi bien
dans les entrepôts de west à rio negro
donc l'aéroport international qui un peu
sur les hauteurs que dans l'aéroport du
centre ville qui en plein centre de
medellin qu'un aéroport historique qui
l'aéroport de yala et vera et à cet
aéroport la west avait un hangar qui
était un gars ou d'où il opérait la
plupart de ses vols sur des petits
avions et donc nous arrivons avec mon
équipe sûre de la zone des hangars de
wes caribéenne et là surprise j'arrive
devant le hangar et je ne crois pas mes
yeux
il se trouve que l'on garde ouest était
le même hangar que le hangar qui
abritait les avions de pablo escobar que
j'avais déjà filmé en ce même endroit là
en 91 alors que j'étais jeune caméramens
avec le correspondant de tf1 l'amérique
latine est donc là tout d'un coup ça
fait tilt quand même très étonnant comme
coïncidence et les coïncidences ne se
sont pas arrêtés là
l'histoire qui mène à la west c'est
l'histoire d'une génération en
génération en gros ils sont presque tous
nés dans les années 50 et sont tous nés
à m'aider c'est une zone qui est une
zone industrielle
sauf que vers la fin de l'année sont en
pleine d industrialisation
il ya énormément de chômage et même des
entrepreneurs sont préoccupés parce que
nos entreprises ne rapporte plus donc à
partir de là il se trouve que à ce
moment là il ya quelque chose de nouveau
qui arrive dans la région et qui produit
énormément d'argent et largement
l'équipe et cette chose là cette chose
nouvelle
c'est la drogue et l'exportation de
cocaïne donc il y avait des montagnes
d'argent qui se retrouvaient à bulles
est libre et il fallait absolument
ventilé tout ça donc il ya eu tout un
tas de solutions qui ont été trouvés
c'était le début d'une grande industrie
du tourisme pourquoi parce que le
touriste ça permettait de blancheur de
la et l'endroit favori l'ul du tourisme
à ce moment là surtout pour les
investisseurs de médine c'était une
petite île dans les caraïbes au large du
nicaragua ni colombienne
isabelle st andrews sur cette île à
partir sur mon moral
enfin les à l'essence du début des
années 80 il ya de nouveaux
entrepreneurs du tourisme qui emmène des
milliers de personnes et l'idée c'est
que plus vous avez de milliers de
personnes teese qui vont sur place plus
vous pouvez justifier que ces personnes
et dépenser de l'argent liquide et donc
à partir de là
l'argent est blanchi d'où la nécessité
ce moment là de créer une compagnie
aérienne et puisse emmener les gens
régulièrement et surtout demandez vous
un grand nom entre la colombie et san
andres et c'est là que naît west
caribbean alors à sainte anne il donc
l'un des fondateurs fondateur principal
de la compagnie pourra être ensuite
incité est il condamné pour blanchiment
d'argent qui était propriétaire de
l'ouest il ya toujours pas mal de
questions pourquoi parce que si on
regarde sur le papier et à tout un tas
de noms qui sont des gens qui sont ceux
qui sont aux postes importants de
l'ouest
le problème là dedans c'est pas
tellement les gens qui sont il ya
personne là dedans qu dont on sait de
quoi que ce soit
de négatif le problème c'est pas
tellement parce qu'ils sont c'est ce
qu'ils ne sont pas aucun d'entre eux
n'est la moindre expérience en
aéronautique
aucun d'entre eux mais un businessman
aucun d'entre eux n'est connue par le
milieu de transport aérien dans le cul
de manière à dire ce sont des grands
inconnus et en général c'est un signe
très très peur quand sur les grands
inconnus c'est que ce sont des hommes de
paille comme on lire en espagnol détesta
féroce c'est à dire qu'ils signent alors
que il travaille pour d'autres est ce
que tout le monde dise et que l'argent
qui est mis au départ et qui permet à la
web devenir de petites compagnies qui en
gros dessert sans adresse en compagnie
nationale colombienne qui commence à les
servir tout un fan zone tout le monde
dit que cet argent vient d'un grand chef
para minutes le chef paramilitaire dès
qu'ils ont gagné ils ont repris qui a
été pendant un certain temps
le business manoeuvré par les guérillas
c'est à dire celui de la transformation
de qoqani
la façon dont on a commencé ouest m'a
beaucoup étonnée elle a débuté ses
opérations avec une flotte composée de
l' est un avion d'environ 18 ou 19
passagers datée r42 de fabrication
franco italienne et 2md de fabrication
nord-américaine de 140 150 places il m'a
donc semblé que c'était une gamme très
diversifiée parce que l'entreprise
opérait aussi bien dans l'aviation
régionale que dans la ncaa et
l'international dans le monde entier et
l'aviation commerciale est un négoce
très coûteux qui demande beaucoup de
ressources financières et nécessite de
grands capitaux je crois donc que les
entreprises doivent naître modestement
et se développer particulièrement dans
un milieu comme le colombien comme le
latino américains ou les ressources ne
sont pas très abondantes elles avaient
beaucoup de bureaux de personnels
techniques et d'équipements en somme
beaucoup de choses pour couvrir
l'opération de cette diversité d'avion
et de cette quantité de route c'est très
difficile pour une compagnie aérienne de
se maintenir avec les coûts que ce type
de croissance implique
c'était une compagnie qui avait
plusieurs avions mais les avions est en
très mauvais état
il ne leur restait plus qu'un avion qui
pouvaient voulait donc cet avion devait
faire cette nombre de voix intérieure et
et des voleurs internationaux à van
devenue aux antilles avant devenu en
martinique et en guadeloupe
donc c'est un avion qui était
extrêmement sollicités
au moment où il ya eu le coche
nous sommes dans la longueur de la west
caribbean
c'est ici que sont réalisées les
services de manutention des grands
avions de la compagnie les md il peut
recevoir deux avions modèle md 80 80 ou
90 comme si vous voyez ici
en ce moment nous avons deux avions
maintenance sur celui qui se trouve là
au fond le travail est pratiquement
terminée sur sept autres les travaux
vient à peine de commencer
tous les avions sont 110 m haies le
dernier que la compagnie a qui est
justement le 74 qui avait à peu près
huit mois auprès ce canon de service
dans la compagnie
ceux ci sont plus anciens dans
l'entreprise ils vont sur leurs deux ans
ce mois-ci ils n'ont pas été remis en
service à temps parce que
malheureusement le coût des pièces de
rechange est très élevé en fait elle
était déjà à l'idée mais nous avons
immédiatement utilisé sur l'autre avion
qui est empire condition que ce dernier
l'acquisition de pièces de rechange
était prioritaire pour voir garantissant
sécurité puisque à ce moment là il était
en opération
les spécifications de l'avion qui volait
sont pratiquement compatibles avec cet
avion qui est le 43 0
nous avons donc effectivement utilisé
quelques composants de cet avion nous
avons dû utiliser cinq ou six pièces de
cet avion sur le 74 en fait chaque fois
que l'équipage faisait d'un rapport
d'anomalie ou de feuilles de l'avion
nous faisions immédiatement le travail
de conviction
si nous ne l'avions pas les pièces
approprié au magasin nous devions venir
ici nous devions suivre l'avion durant
toute la semaine parce que de toute
façon à ce moment là c'était la seule
manière de pouvoir continuer à voler
quand on regarde de près la liste des
pièces très élevé d'un avion sur l'autre
on constate qu'il s'agissait d'une
pratique courante dans l'entreprise
entre février et août 2005
plus d'une trentaine de pièces ont été
cannibalisés sur les deux autres avions
en panne au profit de l'appareil qui
s'est crashé le 16 août
cette liste de pièces récupérées sur des
appareils hors service n'est d'ailleurs
pas exhaustive car elle a été constituée
à partir de la traduction partielle du
dossier de maintenance traduction sur
laquelle le juge ne s'est jamais penché
le marché noir de pièces d'aéronautique
est terrible pas seulement colombien en
équateur aux états unis mais dans le
monde entier
il ya des commerçants qui en fait un
trafic et sont toujours à la recherche
de pièces
beaucoup de ces pièces retirer qui parce
qu'elles ont atteint leurs limites
spécifié paraissent en parfait état à
vue d'oeil
elles paraissent bonnes
c'est donc très facile quelqu'un qu'elle
récupère alors au lieu d'être jeté elles
sont cachées pour être vendus au marché
noir
comme si elles étaient neuf j'achète je
vends des pièces des composants d'avions
au marché noir
c'est ça mon activité ces pièces sont
fournis des employés et qui les tirent
de leur entreprise et les vendent ils
les vendent à des gens comme moi qui à
leur tour négocié leurs ventes à une
autre entreprise et les petites
compagnies en mauvaise situation
économique comme west caribbean
plusieurs transporteurs de fret et même
des entreprises de fret panaméenne
achètent des pièces comme ça au marché
noir sans aucun papier sans aucune
traçabilité rien
ce qui les intéresse c'est simplement de
gagner un peu d'argent en achetant à bas
prix ces pièces et ce matériel au marché
noir c'est bien meilleur marché
en outre on économise les formalités
d'exportation de nationalisation en
somme on économise toute la paperasse ce
qui permet de gagner du temps pour que
l'avion ne reste pas trop longtemps au
sol
cela diminue ainsi la perte d'argent
west caribbean oui ils ont acheté
plusieurs pièces pour travailler sur
l'avion qui a eu l'accident
il n'y a pas longtemps ils ont passé une
liste à beaucoup de gens qui travaillent
dans ce négoce de vente de ce matériel
et sept avions ont été immobilisés dans
le hangar comme c'était le seul qui
volaient il avait besoin de ces pièces
pour le remettre rapidement service
c'était pour un mac douglas 82 qu'ils
avaient à medellin dans le hangar de
maintenance en plus le personnel
technique qui est allé à medellin pour
faire le travail sur cet avion est passé
par ici pour récupérer ce matériel j'ai
vendu plusieurs pièces plusieurs pièces
de rechange à cette entreprise ce qui
s'est passé c'est que west caribbean
devait plusieurs quinzaine de salaires à
ses employés
elle devait dix ou douze quinzaine
plusieurs employés ont alors quitté
l'entreprise des inspecteurs des
ingénieurs et des techniciens et je sais
par exemple que quelques-uns qui
contrôlait le travail qui se faisait sur
l'avion
entre 3,74 son parti il n'y avait donc
plus d'inspecteurs pour contrôler et
réviser le travail que les techniciens
faisait il n'y avait plus personne pour
vérifier si le travail avait été fait
s'il était bien fait ou mal fait il n'y
avait plus aucun contrôle
l'homme de 81 par définition n'est pas
un avion poubelle puisqu'elle n'a encore
beaucoup qui volent dans le monde le
sait néanmoins il était à l'évidence
exploité par une compagnie poubelle
parce que pourquoi on peut dire une
compagnie poubelle
c'est une compagnie qui kanem
cannibalise ses avions pour faire voler
un seul avion qui lui reste une
compagnie qui est pas capable de payer
ses factures de carburant
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que les pilotes
je pense on prie beaucoup de de pétrole
au départ de panama parce qu'ils
voulaient pas rouler à fort de france
une compagnie qui paye pas son personnel
et les pilotes qui sont pas payés depuis
six mois
avec tous ces éléments là c'est une
compagnie poubelle
dans les heures qui ont suivi le crash
j'ai acheté toute la presse à paris et
les quotidiens les plus importants le
monde le figaro le parisien ont vraiment
titré en première page sur l'état de
l'avion et l'un d'entre eux a même fait
un gros titre avion poubelle
donc pour moi il était clair dès le
départ que l'état de l'avion était en
cause dans l'accident
les problèmes financiers et
l'aéronautique n'a pas été assez
strictes pour arrêter les aéronefs d'une
entreprise qui avait quatorze avions
dont seulement deux étaient en opération
parce que les autres avaient été
suspendus de bronze pour divers motifs
au terme de leur mission en avril 2005
les inspecteurs daniel palacios et
milton jiménez demande que soient
enlevées à la west sa capacité de
maintenance pour mcdonnell double x 1 -
avant le crash l'un des inspecteurs
préconise la suspension des activités de
la west si elle ne se conforme pas aux
exigences de l'aéronautique civile
colombienne les demandes des inspecteurs
n'ont jamais été suivies par les
autorités colombiennes
mais pourquoi avait même commencé un
travail qu'il n'avait pas les moyens de
réaliser
il ya eu alors des tentatives de
négociations mais comme elles n'ont pas
abouti le ministère de la défense lui
adjugé un contrat de trois mille
millions de lopes confère du transport
de trucs en colombie
je parle des liens des associés de
wasquehal ibm
était une entreprise qui cède 1,10 à
l'exploitation d'hélicoptères aux
services qu'elle offre aux compagnies
pétrolières est aussi dernièrement comme
nous l'avons vu aux forces militaires
j'ai eu l'occasion comme journaliste de
m'y intéresser avant même l'accident la
west sans même savoir que younes était
il faisait partie des packers étaient le
propriétaire de west ham
et ouais d'état
akira silhouette je me suis intéressé
pourquoi parce que il y avait des
indicateurs qui montrent avec eliane
death disposait le contrat extrêmement
avantageux avec le gouvernement
colombien des titres akd ministère de la
défense pour bouger pour mobiliser les
transporter les troupes au canada donc
vous avez une compagne hélicoptère qui
commence à avoir grande d'état qui est
liée historiquement à la famille de au
clan qui entourent et qui va prendre
position et racheter directement west
caribbean à ce moment-là du bondy avec
l'argent du camid la lazio aucune preuve
normal qu'on peut voir façon très claire
c'est que la compagnie wes caribéenne
commence à les servir des zones où
personne n'avait auparavant et ils sont
justement les autres deviennent des
zones le chef par hamid elian death et
west caribbean airways partagent le même
hangar les mêmes bureaux et ont une
comptabilité communes elles sont
liquidés en 2007 soit deux ans après la
catastrophe du 16 août
mais plus que les experts ou les
techniciens les mieux placés pour parler
de la compagnie sont sans doute les
passagers vous allez enfin de passer les
vacances de la semaine sainte sur les
îles de san andres et providence ça
s'est passé on m'a le matin du jour de
notre retour nous repartions à midi la
manière il y avait eu l'accident du
petit avion de west caribbean sur l'île
providentiel sommes arrivés à l'aéroport
de son adresse ou retourner à medellin
hier au gothard nous avons trouvé un
climat de panique ce peur et d'angoissé
il y avait plusieurs blessés dans les
reports et dans notre avis valent deux
blessés de ses partisans avaient été
installés à l'arrière de la cabine des
passagers
évidemment cette situation faisait que
s'il voulait passagers était un peu
tendu et parler c'est en bois c'est dans
l'avion and good year se vendre de saint
andré à medellin dure à peu près mineurs
minutes et un certain moment peut-être
quinze minutes de l'arrivée à medellin
on a senti que l'avion se dépressurisée
les masques sont tombés automatiquement
comme vous pouvez le voir sur les photos
qui nous avions un appareil photo et
nous avons pris ces clichés sur un monde
nous avons vu comment les masques sont
tous tombés sur les passagers en un
instant le plus préoccupant c'est que
j'ai pas lié quand j'ai vu que les
hôtesses étaient plus après que les
passagers
elle était assise sur les sièges de côté
et évidemment ça nous a fait encore plus
peur cette situation a duré peut-être
quelques secondes
l'avion a commencé à descendre
rapidement et on a mis les masques il ya
une photo on voit les gens
moment où il met les marnaises un moment
après tout est redevenu normal et
finalement nous avons atterri à
l'aéroport de medellin est évidemment
nous espérions qu'à la sortie de l'avion
quelqu'un nous expliquerait ce qui
s'était passé
nous avons décidé d'appeler un des
pilotes de wade
le pilote nous a demandé ce que nous
allions d'aviation elio lui avons
répondu que comme justement nous ne
comprenons rien nous avions besoin qu'il
nous explique ce qui s'était passé alors
il est venu et nous expliquer qu'il ne
s'était rien passé de grave et est
finalement mais nous ont communiqué que
le reste avait décidé de changer d'avion
si vous retournez à la hauteur ce qui
fait qu'un vol qui a vraiment c'est à
lundi s'est finalement terminée à minuit
à mon bonheur
ici vous voyez il ya les dates de
tournée vol je voyage presque tous les
jours et celui ci c'est le voyage que
j'avais programmé pour le 8 août
cependant la tente dans la salle 6
l'avion est arrivé et on a senti quand
il est tombé fort il semble non il ne
semble pas il a effectivement cassé une
jambe du train d'atterrissage par la
suite
l'hôtesse celle qui est maman le petit
kiosque celle qui nous acheminer vers
l'avion nous a confirmé effectivement
que l'avion avait eu un problème et que
son train d'atterrissage avait été
endommagé c'est alors au tour de 9h15
qui nous ont communiqué qu effectivement
le vol ne pouvait pas partir et qu'ils
étaient reportés à une heure l'après
midi
je leur ai donc dit que ça ne
m'interesse jours parce que j'ai
dévouement sur tout le territoire
national est en principe je prends avoir
à 6h30 ou 5 heures du matin au plus tard
pour votre beauté alentours de 5h et de
lui ou six heures et demie à venir
ils m'ont répondu que malheureusement il
n'avait pas d'autres avions ce jour là
que les mardis n'avait pas devant leur
destination
et que la seule option que j'avais
c'était de prendre le vol du mercredi 10
août à 6h30 ici à l'ayraultport le
mercredi je suis arrivée de nouveaux
aéroports à peu près à 6h30
peu après ils nous ont dit que l'avion
avait des failles mécanique dont je ne
sais pas quoi et ne pouvait pas partir
et nous ont proposé de reporter le vol
jusqu'au vendredi
je me suis alors mis en colère je ne
pouvais plus rester ici je perds de
l'argent du travail du temps et comme
entreprise ça me compliquer les choses
c'est ainsi qu'en fin de compte ils nous
ont transféré dans un vol de l'aéroport
lic
ils m'ont demandé comme on arrivait à
les reports de rio mais g et dénis je
confirme avec la west caribbean mon vol
de retour à 6h20 c'est à dire de nuit
avec un avion qui arrivait à medenine le
soir nous avons décollé et dès le début
du vol l'avion commençait à avoir comme
des mouvements brusques
le pilote a alors annoncé qu'il y avait
un problème de pressurisation qu'il ne
fallait pas se préoccuper que le vol
continuer quand l'avion atterrit nous
sommes descendus et c'est alors qu'ils
nous ont passé un petit ticket bloc
grand plus ou moins comme ça en nous
disons que nous devions attendre un
moment il semble que nous étions de nous
voiler report rio negro medellin en fin
de compte ce n'était pas des problèmes
de pressurisation c'était des files
mécanique
c'est ce que m'a confirmé adrian à
l'employée avec laquelle j'ai discuté et
kim acheminés vers un hôtel là mais
mario nerfs parce que j'ai beaucoup
d'éclat mais j'étais très fâché avec eux
pendant que nous attendions l'avion de
nouveau décoller sans nous ils ont dit
que c'était pour un vol de test je crois
qu'ils ont fait le vote sans
autorisation de la tour et pour ça ils
ont été sanctionnés
évidemment ils n'ont pas pu sortir de
toute la nuit
c'est qu'ils sont très dépassée qui ne
pardonnent s'il m'entendait le centre
est dépassé
le lendemain je n'ai pas voulu retourner
avec la west caribbean j'ai demandé à
voyager avec la et andré tour lucas
sinon je ne voyagerai pas et ça a été de
nouveau un problème pour qu'il me rende
mon billet pour un de l'aéro repubblica
il ne voulait pas me l'échanger il
voulait que je le paye de ma poche il
savait qu'il n'avait qu'un seul avion
il n'aurait pas dû mettre la pression
avec autant de vols pour un seul avion
lorsque nous sommes entrés dans l'avion
dès que l'avion décoller les peines et
donc les personnels navigants
commerciaux les hôtesses de la compagnie
se sont toutes affalé au fond de
l'appareil chaque personne a pu une
banquette exercice où se reposer elle
était épuisée mort de fatigue
safetic elles ont dormi car c'est par la
fatigue
premièrement deuxième chose quand même
c'est pour moi le fait de voir un cafard
ont circulé comme ça à même le sol de
l'avion les nombreuses fois où j'ai
voyagé je n'ai pas eu l'occasion de voir
ça donc pour moi c'était le témoignage
d'un entretien aléatoire de l'appareil
et puis un autre élément quand même
assez extraordinaire
c'est la porte du fond parce que j'étais
au fond de l'appareil voir une hôtesse
fermer la porte du fond avec une pince
donc ça ça m'avait littéralement
interpellé et puis le dernier élément
quand même c'est que j'étais placé au
fond de l'appareil est juste derrière
moi il y avait les hôtesses qui dormait
et au bout d'une heure à une heure
quinze de vol à peu près il ya eu ce
bruit métallique j'ai entendu du côté
des réacteurs ça faisait 4 à kathak tac
tac tac tac tac tac et cetera
bon ça a duré à peu près allez on va
dire deux minutes à peu près et ça ça a
fait tilt et je me suis posé la question
aux yeux mais qu'est ce qui se passe
quoi quand on est monté dans l'avion
manifestement il y avait des problèmes
d'entretien de l'avion
aussi bien au niveau des sièges des
ceintures de nos d'aidé ça s'appelle des
formalités
en cas de problèmes qui n'ont pas été
faites en fait les consignes n'ont pas
été faites il faisait très froid dans
l'avion
donc il n'y avait pas mal d'anomalies
bon moi je suis pas spécialiste des
compagnies aériennes donc je n'ai pas
j'ai pas tout noté mais en tout cas rien
qu'au départ on a bien senti que l'avion
n'était pas un avion bien entretenu
j'étais pas tranquille dans l'avion j'ai
déjà eu des trous d'air sur d'autres
compagnies
mais là c'était pas pareil aussi on va
on va dire que c'est une impression
d'être respectés mais c'est pas vrai
parce que tout ce que je dis là il n'y
avait pas encore le crash le 15 août je
crois que c'était un lundi et on a passé
on a déjeuné chez ma mère et on a passé
le déjeuner à discuter des conditions
dans lesquelles on avait voyagé
parce que j'avais des questions à poser
à mon frère sur un petit peu toutes les
sensations j'avais ressenti les
bouillies anormaux dans l'avion on
sentait qu on sentait qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui n'était pas correcte
et si je peux aller plus loin moi j'ai
eu envie en descendant de l'avion retour
le 8 de demander aux gens de ne pas
embarquer dans l'avion sans éthique très
doux je vais vous dire pourquoi parce qu
au retour j'ai eu une sensation
d'insécurité gala mais vraiment de
sécurité parce que à tout moment l'avion
raquet il y avait des craquements
permanence à l'intérieur de l'avion
ça bougeait un peu par de partout des
soutes à bagages
ben s'ouvrait pendant le vol on a été
réveillés pense à plusieurs fois des
bagages qui sont tombés sur la tête des
gens parce que ça s'ouvrait la clim du
cookie qui fuyait enfin qui goûtaient
bon on sentait qu un seul avion qui
avait quand même un certain nombre de
deux heures de vol le vol de retour
vu l'heure donc 2h du matin était très
pénible
ce jour là effectivement l'avion était
un peu en plus mauvais état qu'à l'aller
comprenez les trous d'airs le siège bout
j'ai donc bon ça c'était un relativement
inquiétant c'est un peu difficile parce
que bon on était fatigués de par la
tante et c'est vrai qu on a eu beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de trous d'air et bon
c'était pas très agréable comme vole sur
sur le retour j'avoue qu'on n'était pas
de conflit long retour la compagnie
étant habitué à avoir du retard
je pense que les organisateurs fait en
tout cas pour le groupe auquel
j'appartenais nous avait déjà prévenu
que ce n'était pas la peine de se
présenter à 10 heures ce serait
peut-être midi ou 18 heures finalement
on a su je ne suis pas comment que
c'était 18 heures et quand on s'est
présenté à 18 heures il n'y avait pas
vraiment de formalité
donc on a attendu je crois jusqu'à 22 ou
23 heures qu'on a dû partir vers 3
heures du matin donc pour un vol prévu à
10h écouter l'avion était
initialement annoncée autour de 15h40
décollage de pointe à pitre vers panama
city
l'avion est parti à 3h30 du matin le
lendemain
donc si c'est un temps d'attentes une
seconde il noce je peux comprendre que
si on veut le chant théâtre y avoir deux
trois quatre cinq heures six heures
maximum à 12 heures
moi depuis que j'ai encadré ces groupes
à partir du 9 juillet systématiquement
les groupes sont arrivés plus tard c'est
à dire le mardi matin au lieu du lundi
soir et sont également repartis plus
tard c'est à dire le le lundi soir au
lieu du lundi matin
alors moi j'avais ramené donc les gens
le lundi soir après leur dîner
les gens avaient procédé normalement à
l'enregistrement l'ambiance était bonne
était détendue les gens s'étaient fait
évidemment à l'idée de ce retard et
avait eu pour ça une compensation
ensuite je les ai donc quitté
chaleureusement le lendemain matin
il se fait que j'ai dû revenir à
l'aéroport très tôt le matin je n'étais
pas convoqué comme guide
j'y allais à titre personnel pour
emmener des gens que je connaissais sur
les coups de 6 heures du matin et en
jetant un coup d'oeil aux arrivées alors
que le prochain groupe était prévu je
n'ai vu personne
je me suis simplement dit tiens c'est
bizarre
et puis en prenant mon taxi pour revenir
chez moi donc sur les coudes de 6h30 7h
du matin une collègue guide m'appelle en
larmes pour me m'apprendre la triste
nouvelle
donc de cet accident d'avion du groupe
que nous avions eu toute la semaine
passée
j'avais 80 cartes postales encore à
poster et
et croyez moi ça a été dur j'ai lu les
quelques cartes postales y avait
notamment une carte postale d'une maman
pour sa fille qui habite en métropole
des cartes postales pour des amis donc
mardi dans l'après midi je me suis rendu
au bureau de poste pour envoyer ses
cartes postales et puis ensuite donc
évidemment j'ai essayé de suivre
toutes les nouvelles se rapportant à cet
affreux accident tout ce qu'on pouvait
trouver dans les médias puisque je
n'avais que ça en tête évidemment ça
nous a tous choqués nous les quatre
guides qui avions accompagné ces groupes
durant toute la semaine
mon ami m'appelle et il me dit tu as
écouté la radio je lui dis non il me dit
assieds toi donc je m'assieds et il me
dit tu sais l'avion du panama est tombée
en fin ou hilla est tombé au dessus du
venezuela
et là je crois que je suis resté une
heure de temps sans pouvoir dit aux
amours avec une sensation je vois la
première sensation que j'ai eu c'est une
culpabilité immense mais c'est difficile
d'en parler parce que pourquoi on a
échappé à ça on avait la possibilité
même si elle n'est pas vrai mais on
avait la possibilité de dit aux autres
n'y allez pas mais parce que ça ne se
fait pas parce qu'on n'a pas d'élément
parce qu'on n'est pas une autorité on
peut pas le faire et parce qu'on le fait
juste sur les sensations et il m'a fallu
vraiment beaucoup de temps pour dépasser
ça et et admettre qu'en quelque part on
pouvait être un puissant mais je pense
que si je vous dis ça ici aujourd'hui
c'est parce que je pense que c'est
peut-être une des grands choses que je
peux encore faire parce que c'est très
difficile
on partage à ce moment là tout ce que
les familles ont vécu de manière
rétrospective mais moi je vécu d'abord
la culpabilité avant de vivre
donc je me suis dit que j'aurais dû
avait aussi aux quelque notoriété
qu'elle compte pour leur dire que cet
avion rare il faut pas qu'ils voyagent
ça a été mon regret vraiment
disons que je fais avec je fais avec
je fais avec c'est pas une chose facile
à vivre
est ce qu'il n'ya peut-être pas des
intérêts économiques entre différents
pays
tu t'étais sous ces dossiers en échange
je te donne ça on ne sait pas on n'est
pas là pouvoir pour savoir ce qui se
passe un truc entre les chefs d'état
ces gens sachent qu à ce jour jamais un
juge
un policier français n'est talent au
siège de l'ouest qu'en haut débit pour
j'ai au moins semblant d'enquêté quand
messi continue elle se déplace avec
madame fort où j'ai deux juges
d'instruction avec monsieur belotti le
magistrat instructeur
non le l'expert bardon avec le
responsable du brigham de transport
aérien ils arrivent dans la capitale et
il demande à la medellin on leur dit non
il faut comprendre aussi comment évolue
la ville de medellin
cette ville de medellin était
industriels les industriels commencent à
investir dans une sorte de casino de la
drogue propose pablo escobar qui marche
à tous les coups
à partir de là ça donne des taux de
rentabilité fantastique et à partir de
ce moment-là ça permet l'émergence d'une
nouvelle classe politique urbaine est
liée en gros ce milieu et parmi les gens
qui sont liés à ce milieu on trouve un
entrepreneur qui loue des hélicoptères
est il à son entrepôt juste à côté de
celui de pablo escobar et cet
entrepreneur qui loue des hélicoptères
c'est le père de celui qui allait
devenir le président de colombie alvaro
uribe et cette personne bien les
hélicoptères un peu à tout le monde et
on sait que c'est un des proches de
pablo escobar le père du rib et qui par
ailleurs lui en tout cas était
suffisamment prudent pour nous avoir
laissés à strictement aucune trace
criminelle a été aussi directeur de
l'aéronautique civile colombienne et son
jeune fils alvaro uribe s'est retrouvé
très très tôt en politique et il a été
aussi directeur de l'aéronautique civile
dian piot qui au début des années 80 au
moment où justement le ciel de cette
région là étaient remplis d'avion qui
transportait de la drogue pour
l'exporter
donc vous imaginez bien que quand on est
directeur de l'aéronautique civile
on doit gérer d une abondance de wolf
qui
sur 30 l'accident de russes caribbean
pendant la semaine sainte
accident qui a coûté la vie à huit
personnes nous avons eu un débat au
congrès pour dénoncer l'insécurité
aérienne et le fait que l'aéronautique
civile
notre plus grande autorité dans le
domaine ne pesait pas ce qu'elle devait
faire et que le laxisme la forme
olympique de traiter le sujet pourrait
nous mener à de nouveaux accidents et un
autre accident survenu
on le débat interne du congrès de
colombie nous avons eu les preuves que
l'entreprise west caribbean avait été
sanctionné à deux occasions au bar de
lourdes amendes
la première c'est sur quoi de ses avions
des cargos ou de passagers
l'aéronautique n'a pas expliqué si cet
étroit de passagers sont trop de fret
mais il y avait du surpoids
la deuxième sanction avait été impliqué
excès d'heures de travail de ses pilotes
ici nous avons dit que certains pilotes
avaient travaillé 11 12 13 14 et jusqu'à
15 heures d'affilée est né dans cette
circonstance un être humain normal ne
peux pas répondre à ses obligations et
moins encore dans ce type de travail qui
demande plus d'implication et des forces
éducation et fois ci on a cru nous avons
cru nous avons pensé que l'entreprise
aurait dû paralysé ses avions avant le
dernier accident d'un témoin que
l'entreprise a commencé avec 13 avions
et pour divertir constance elle a
ensuite réduit sa flotte à quatre avions
et au moment du dernier accident n avait
que deux avions un qui volait et l'autre
au seul pour avarie technique important
une autre prise réduite un seul avion
qui demande aux aviateurs de travailler
15 qui sûrement ne fait pas une
maintenance suffisant et qui a beaucoup
de problèmes financiers aurait dû être
arrêtée depuis longtemps et c'est là que
nous croyons qu'il ya eu des influences
ou des privilèges qui ont permis que
l'entreprise continue de voler et qu'est
ce qui se passe c'est qu'à partir du
moment où alvaro uribe commence à avoir
des problèmes avec certains des chefs
paramilitaires problème de pouvoir de
lutte de pouvoir avec certains des chefs
paramilitaires et bien la compagnie ne
reçoit plus le cash qui devait recevoir
qui lui permettait de continuer à opérer
à perte
donc à partir de se rendre à cette
compagnie comment ça
perdre de l'argent mais à la fois comme
elle est supportée par un réseau
d'intérêts qui inclut tout le monde
jusqu'au président la république elle
est quand même autorisé à continuer à
opérer et donc c'est dans cette
situation là qu'on va retrouver cette
compagnie conditions extrêmement
difficiles
il existe un autre détail le directeur
de l'aéronautique bon administrativement
du ministre des transports
mais en réalité il est nommé par le
président de la république mon point de
vue c'est que l'élément qui relie tous
et pas seulement ce cas là c'est la
structure de l'hérault civile nous
sommes convaincus elle nous affirmons
que le problème c'est clair au civil est
juge et partie
elle administre et en même temps quand
elle ne remplit pas son rôle
d'administration elles vont guetter
c'est donc très difficile qu'un
organisme qui administre et on met ses
obligations enquête sur lui et avaient
accusé lui même une fois par an il faut
passer un examen de l'air au civil que
l'on appelle profit siens sur cet examen
se déroule devant des inspecteurs ont
des inspecteurs délégués en accord avec
les normes aéronautiques explique il
existe des cas et nous avons des
documents qui le ronge où les
inspecteurs qui vont faire passer ses
examens n'ont pas la licence nécessaire
pour l'avion que le pilote opère c'est
illégal
je suis rentré lundi qu' civile j'étais
embauché et un tank et et prestataires
de services us c'est à dire quelqu'un
qui fait des services mais pas employer
et six employés et c'est le cas des plus
de la moitié des gens qui font mon
travail c'est à dire des inspecteurs des
réalités oui et d'opérations aussi des
gens qui travaillent de route ictv ils
font ce qu'ils peuvent avec ceux qui
qu'on le donne
il ya pas mal de souvenirs qui sont
qualifiés mais sont pas actualiser la
plupart pourquoi parce qu'il ya une loi
qui interdit les gouvernements de et
donner des formations aux gens qui sont
pas des fonctionnaires mais comme la
plupart d'entre nous comme moi j'étais
là aussi j'étais des gens qui
travaillaient comme au service des gens
qui fait ses services et pas des
fonctionnaires
donc on ne dompte pas vraiment le type
des formations qu'on demande et dont on
a besoin tant que leurs antiques civile
est dirigé et
par des gens qui ont des intérêts et
politiques et faire devenir et au
congrès au devenir président comme les
mêmes président arrivé et il doit
commencer à faire des compromis avec
d'autres types des forces politiques
avec des gens qu'ils sont moches mais
qui sont pas forcément forte en
technique mais fortin politique donc oui
il ya pas mal de gens qui sont pistonnés
mais dans le groupe dans les qualités la
plupart des gens étaient des gens qui
avaient des compétences techniques
même s'il s'était pas et est formé pour
des trucs et spécialisés et c'est ça qui
manque des gens et spécialisés pour
assurer la sécurité rien pratiquement
c'était une tragédie annoncée quand il
ya un accident aérien beaucoup de
problèmes et de failles d'inspection et
de surveillance interagissent et se
rejoindre l'état colombien pour
plusieurs facteurs a réduit
substantiellement les contrôles les
inspections et la surveillance
il n'y a pas suffisamment de contrôleurs
aériens il n'y a pas de ressources pour
les payer et leur niveau professionnel
laisse beaucoup à désirer
en conséquence ils ne remplissent pas
leur fonction le bien inspecter et de
veiller sur les avions qui circulent
non seulement dans l'espace aérien de
colombie mais aussi à l'extérieur
oui il y a eu du favoritisme des
privilèges envers west caribbean durant
les quatre dernières années
c'était d'une entreprise au bord de la
faillite d'une entreprise qui ne paient
pas depuis trois mois l'équipage qui
s'est accidenté
une entreprise qui ne respectaient pas
les standards de révision
d'inspection et de surveillance et
malheureusement il faut le dire aussi
l'aéronautique civile l'organisme
aéronautique de colombie n'a pas été à
la hauteur de ces contrôles et cet
accident on va sûrement pu être évité
dix ans c'est long dix ans d'attenté il
y a beaucoup de choses que nous avons
appris que les juges ne veulent pas
reconnaître comme vérité et ça ça fait
mal sur le plan historique
on al pendant ses dix ans cette réalité
c'est à dire d'un côté des engagements
précis au fur à mesure une baisse des de
l'implication de l'état et du juge dans
la possible on a eu un petit rebond il
ya de cela trois ans quand madame
taubira pris l'engagement de débloquer
les fonds
puisque les éléments de la procédure
c'était qu'il fallait traduire des
documents mais de puissants on a eu le
maintien de cette position et la
décision du procureur récente de
demander le nomdieu la position du
procureur général de la martinique
d'appel de fort de france et de son
cousin un dépaysement et la
démonstration qui a cette volonté qu'on
en finisse le discours qui aujourd'hui
nous est fait et un discours vous
comprenez en a déjà dépassé beaucoup
d'argent de frontières et c'est donc en
fin de compte une des missions de l'état
de la justice pas à ce qu'ils aient
reste un drame avec toute une série de
de conséquences pour les victimes
jusqu'à toujours l'instruction tels que
fait elle pose problème elle pose
problème parce que il y a bien trop de
d'éléments suspicieux qui quelque part
et on peut comprendre les familles
empêche de croire à une réelle
manifestation de la vérité
on a été devant deux ministres on a fait
le forcing au concert est ouvert
on n'arrête pas de frapper à des portes
avec tout ce qu'on a pu faire au niveau
de la fca au niveau des familles
d'accueil sylla qu'en france tous les
témoignages qu'on a pu affronter tous
les courriers qu'on a écrit tous les
avocats qu'on a payé bien sûr nous vous
écouter
il est généralement admis qu'un accident
aérien est la résultante de plusieurs
dysfonctionnements
or dans ce crash en particulier la
justice ne retient qu'une cause la faute
des pilotes
les enquêtes techniques ans pour but de
connaître les véritables raisons des
accidents afin de pouvoir les prévenir
des enquêtes judiciaires
elles doivent rechercher les
responsables au culte est
systématiquement les failles et protéger
les responsables n'est pas une attitude
de nature à faire progresser l'aviation
et donc c'est permettre que les mêmes
causes produisent les mêmes effets
non
tout le monde